what would be the most exaggerated fun
way to make coffee we're gonna take
coffee we're gonna evolve it to be what
visual effects artists require a gpu
accelerated cup of coffee until these
guys can prove to me that the time
they're wasting on coffee can be turned
somehow into content
i'm gonna be an absolute tyrant about
this
[Music]
oh you guys
[Music]
[Music]
so good right
whoa whoa whoa dude
oh get back to work
get back to your desk
go
go
i need to get to the studio
you know i'm here this week and i've
noticed another inefficiency where
people are wasting time and it's not
smash no it's coffee
dude i have anywhere between three and
five cups of coffee a day it's it's not
healthy i'm typically like a three to
four guy a day probably uh two to three
maybe four or five six
seven
coffee is an art okay coffee there's a
very specific process that one has to go
through in order to get a good cup of
joe you want to make some coffee here
look it comes in a can okay
you just
take a scoop of it
put it in your water
and you're done you can move on with
your day
the entire process probably takes north
of 20 minutes and that's multiple times
a day and you know this process is so
long so drawn out that it leaves us with
a lot of time on our hands to sit here
and talk and dream of a better future a
better tomorrow i only ask for eight
hours of people's time a day now every
moment that is within that time frame
that's wasted is another wasted
opportunity for content and without
content we have no business until these
guys can prove to me that the time
they're wasting on coffee can be turned
somehow into content i'm gonna be an
absolute tyrant about this
i just dream of the perfect coffee maker
it's efficient it's creative yeah it's
it's not just a
generic boring piece of machinery it has
style
it has bits and bobs
shoots and levers uh accoutrement
what would be the most exaggerated fun
way to make coffee
there is a man named rube and he was the
inventor of the goldbergs the tv show
and the rube goldberg machine yep i
think we could take some inspiration and
so we want to take his vision his idea
of one button push walk away and the
magic happens and apply that here we are
going to take coffee we're going to
evolve it okay we're going to involve
the process to be what visual effects
artists require a gpu accelerated cup of
coffee think of it little boxing gloves
on springs little choo choo little train
a wheels with beans on the back of it
the marble hitting dominoes and knocking
them over and then the domino falls we
want to make that world a reality this
is art man this is art
we are going to put our minds together
to the task of rendering this rue
goldberg machine and making it a reality
but it's a very difficult time-consuming
task we don't really have the time for
it i mean it's a lot of modeling a lot
of texture work what tools do we have at
our disposal
talk to me polycan
it is a 3d scanning app for your phone
i've been a little 3d scanning gremlin
anytime i go out with my friends and
they see like there's a piece of an
engine right there they already know i'm
like
i i can't i can't stop scanning stuff
i've i have a huge library of 3d scans
of just everyday objects it completely
takes out the work of having to model
things for your scenes because for this
rube goldberg machine we could just we
could just scan scan this quesado
throw it in the render and it's already
good to go it's good to render
oh
it's so good it's so good look at this
wow
zoom in on that let me see the subscribe
to the channel
oh
oh my gosh it's so awesome
it eliminates all of the modeling and
all of the texturing and and all that
grunt work that's associated with
getting photo real renders once we scan
all the stuff then we have it forever
now we have a catalog of hundreds of 3d
models that you can use for eternity so
guys i think if we use polycam
we can successfully in a short amount of
time render the coolest most intricate
coffee machine maker rube goldberg thing
in the history of mankind okay so let's
take some time to map out how the
machine would actually operate in the
space of the kitchen and then from there
we can start blocking out the scene in
3d we're going to dedicate some time to
clear the schedule i'm going to tell
jake
we're just going to do it
so we've been at work for a couple days
now and we've made some tremendous
progress i'm really happy me and the
team here we've all separated and taken
on our own individual tasks to help make
this dream a reality
fenner took care of the layout finding
and sourcing such beautiful little
creations to put into our world i don't
know how you found all this stuff how
did you find all that stuff using
polycam's explore page there are so many
weird little scans on there peter's gone
ahead and gotten started on the
character animations our little scans
rigging them up and making them do all
sorts of little goofy things and yeah
jordan has been doing a bunch of the
simulations for this so we have like our
beans sliding through water pouring out
all the different aspects you need to
make coffee
okay sweet so jordan uh oh and peter
come on so i've got the scene kind of
blocked out in blender right now with
all of our nice polycam scans in there
oh wow yeah dude this looks sick uh i'm
starting to block in the camera
animation now that we sort of have the
rough outline of our different events
that we have happening here oh this is
uncomfortable
i can't do this anymore
anyways
so anyways what do you guys think it's
looking dude it's looking freaking
awesome man we're gonna blend into this
animation and out of this animation from
a real world flight but we haven't shot
that yet so it makes it very difficult
to animate the camera
so right now i think our game plan while
we're all here is to shoot that plate so
we'll have that perfect loot we were
thinking it might be fun to have the
kind of reveal of our full bodies and
you see the whole rube goldberg machine
in that right so if we're like here
and then basically dean could come up
come up come up
and then kind of come into the phone
screen
just try a couple different versions of
spilling the coffee so that fenner has a
reason to make you a new one we'll do it
live we'll do it live and
action oh thanks
oh thank you
oh no
oh thanks
[Music]
good shot
oh thanks
what
it's all good man i'll make it another
[Music]
i could have sworn they were here
i'm gonna catch those guys
so we've been using some awesome assets
from the polycam explorer page but we're
getting to a point now where i really
want to you know add in kind of iconic
props from
corridor shorts and different shows that
we've done before so of course i had to
choose this awesome x-wing helmet that
natalie and i made
i'm just kind of walking around i'm
using the manual photo mode it's one of
those things where 3d scanning and
photogrammetry has been around for a
long time but it was always such a
hassle you know gathering your photo
sets and you had to do it all manually
the nice thing with polycam is it kind
of takes all of that manual labor out of
it and allows you just be scanning and
creating really freely it's kind of like
a new form of photography when i was
moving down from vancouver to la we
drove down the pacific coast highway and
i was actually doing scans all along the
way and it's it's really cool because
you can go back and experience those
worlds in 3d space and there's a bunch
of really cool stuff that polly camp is
doing you could check out the cerro
gordo video that quarter actually did
previously where the crew went up there
and they scanned some really cool mine
shafts in this old abandoned town and
there's also a really really cool
project called backup ukraine where
people are basically going around
ukraine and they're scanning different
kind of historical artifacts just
different pieces of architecture
because of the events that are going on
there to kind of have a
almost a 3d archive of the environment
there using polycam it's not just
something that you can use for vfx it's
something that you can use for
architecture game design all sorts of
things polycam is actually starting a
polycam creators program where if you
show off how you use polycam and other
software you can apply and get an
official creator badge on your polycam
profile you just need to make a video
for any kind of polycam tutorial or
showcase make something cool and explain
how you did it kind of like this rube
goldberg machine you'll see our personal
profiles on there and you can actually
save and download all of the captures
that jordan i created for this video all
right so that's it make something cool
get featured go to paulie.com creators
so i'm going to finish up a few more
scans throw them up in my polycam
profile and then see about bringing them
into our 3d rube goldberg machine
so
i noticed they've been working on
something all week but i'm not sure what
it is
they better not be wasting time
otherwise the texas hammer is going to
come down on them hard
let me just get this out of the way real
quick jan is coming in and uh ever since
he got that nerf finger he's been a
problem matt gets it while i do this do
you mind just covering me maybe dual
wield that's pretty sick people are into
that now for me you know when i think of
a rube goldberg machine i think that
there has to be some sort of grounding
for that machine to feel like a working
machine there has to be some working
physics in it that's kind of what i'm
tackling over here in my neck of the
woods and in total i've got 12
simulations to do to make this machine
work in the way that we want it to work
in a working machine all of these
elements would exist for the entire
duration right if it was a working
machine it would be a lot lot more
complex to make and so what we want to
do in the time that we have we want to
simplify we want to cut corners we want
to hide stitches if you don't see the
seams in the working machine to the
viewer's eye it doesn't really matter
now when it comes to simulations like
this there are certain simulations you
can do where you can really just push
play and watch it work like the beans
coming down from the front gates all the
way till they land on the car that works
on its own and that's great because at
the end of the day it's just a matter of
friction velocity and bounce but once
they're in the cart this was the first
element where we ran into some issues
the initial idea for this section was
actually for the beans to fall in and
slowly weigh down the cart dropping the
plank dropping the wagon and all moving
together it wasn't until i got into the
simulation portion that i realized that
was quite a bit tricky because all of a
sudden you've got a couple different
simulations that need to work in tandem
so i thought it was actually best to
separate those different things and
execute them all individually why not
simulate the weight of the plank
dropping from one end to the other as
its own thing now that we have our
finished sim of the plank dipping one
way we can now place in our cart that is
ready with working wheels the cart is
just simply reacting to the dropping of
the plank so now that will roll down and
they don't need to interact with each
other finally the beans coming down into
the cart uh we can wait until all the
beans are into the cart to start the
simulation of the cart going down these
are now three separate simulations so it
looks like it's all working together but
really it's just a cheat if i were to
put all of those into one mechanism and
try to get it to work together that
would take so much more time to
fine-tune each element and that's kind
of the thing with all of these
simulations right we've got i mean i
don't even know how long this full thing
is going to be yet but it's quite a long
machine it's quite a long process and
there's so many dead gaps of space where
simulating would be a total waste of
time like all the liquid simulations for
example we don't need the water to pour
into the bucket sim it's still in the
bucket as it moves all the way down the
zip line and then have that same water
spill out the bottom
instead we can kill the water once it's
in the bucket and then just emit new
water once the axe cuts into the bottom
oh shoot
[Music]
matt what happened
it's not loaded matt i told you you set
me up man
[Laughter]
when you're working in simulations it's
very easy to set up a system that can
absolutely get away from you and so by
segmenting the simulation out i now have
a lot more focused control over each
element in this final render than i
would if every single one relied on
every single other one so we've got our
simulations done right we've got our
rigid body we've got our particles we've
got our flip fluid sims all nice and
done and we're gonna pass them back over
into blender and once that's done we're
gonna pass it over to fenner who's going
to comp the heck out of those darn
things fenner you got this buddy
thanks jordan
so a big part of this video is jordan
peter and i working in tandem that
involves bringing a lot of different
individual elements all together for
this final image and the way we're doing
that is using the foundry's nuke and
combining everything we've created in
comp
so one of my favorite things that was
added into this video peter basically
took those photo scanned versions of
ourselves and he created these little
dudes throughout the entire environment
it turned out great my favorite one here
is jordan jumping on the plunger and
then falling off
it's like those little touches that i
think bring it to life so even though
jordan was able to run a bunch of
awesome simulations for this piece we
just didn't have enough time or
bandwidth to make sure every single
element was going to be a cg render so
for the stuff like the fire i basically
took some geometry
from my blender scene and i was able to
use 2d elements from action vfx and use
them as textures on cards in 3d space
our simple geometry of our fire pit
is now stenciling our fire elements
which gives us a really really nice look
basically being able to add that stuff
in comp allowed us to add in extra
levels of spice after the final render
has already been done so
if we find an area where like oh that
just needs a little bit more dust or
something we're able to add that into
the scene without having to re-render
this massive you know 2000 frame long
blender scene so with all satisfying
renders i've learned that
the most important part is a satisfying
loop
so with those plates that we shot in the
kitchen that essentially became our
transition in and out point we punch
into our polycam coffee maker phone
and go through our render and at the
tail end we basically transition out by
going from our cg scene
and morphing kind of warping to
us all in the kitchen again talking
about our coffee so it's this kind of
idea of transitioning into the polycam
3d world and then back to our real world
because polycam is used to basically
scan the real world and bring it into
the computer we're kind of doing the
inverse of that so there's only a few
things left to do in this video but i
think our cover might be blown it seems
like jake might be on to us so i guess
we'll just have to show them what we've
got right now without any you know sound
mixing or anything in there
yo
listen man uh
see what you've been doing out there
i've been seeing the way you guys do
that coffee thing and uh i want to get
in on that so oh yeah okay man i sound
designed the whole thing what i just i i
was looking from over there i was just
kind of peering just doing my thing
there's like oh there's like a lawnmower
thing there a little bean action that's
so much work yeah
i actually got i got it right here it's
a full mix mastered
exported i think jake's really gonna
love this yeah thanks man godspeed
so uh
that was weird but i'm gonna plug the
sound design in and you know we'll show
it to jake and show him that all this
time we wasted wasn't for nothing
there's been a lot of tension at the
office recently with jake and us about
us wasting time and daydreaming and
thinking of silly fantasies that we want
to make real but today guess what what
we're done it's real it's out of our
head and it is on the canvas and we're
ready to show jake to show him what can
happen when you turn that daydream into
a reality i'll tell you what happens
dreams come true dreams come true dreams
turn into jpeg sequences
[Applause]
[Applause]
what are you doing we have something to
show you what do you mean we we have a
jpeg sequence for you of what it's it's
an animation we just come sit down we
want to show you something so we know
that you've been unhappy with us making
coffee and daydreaming and giggling and
just being youth
you know and we went ahead and we took
some time out of our schedule without
informing you and put all of our dreams
into the computer together as a team we
turned our coffee into content
okay well
show me what you did because i don't
know what is going on here so this
better be good
[Music]
[Music]
uh
so
oh
thanks
what
it's all good man i'll make another
you know actually guys i'm not even mad
no i'm not
this was absolutely beautiful wow look
at the color the scanning everything was
photo scanned which is crazy
the design of the animation the the
overall mechanics of the whatever this
machine is that you've created
makes me kind of thirsty for some coffee
oh my god oh my goodness and you know
what i know that everyone thinks that
i'm the big bad wolf around here who's
just trying to like destroy all
creativity but actually
this is how
the corridor crew channel was created
really i i noticed that ren and
carmichael seemed to be wasting time
and i said
what if we just filmed you guys wasting
time
the pressure that i put on you guys and
and really everybody else around here
i think is really what made this happen
i mean in a way you're you're making
diamonds
from the pressure pressure right you
know wow
it just came to me dude so guys from all
of us who made this and especially jake
who put the pressure on us in the first
place thank you for watching i hope it
brought some joy and some levity and you
know we should be working right now
actually yeah but i think since maybe
you now understand kind of where we're
coming from maybe uh go make a cup of
coffee
huge shout out to polycam for working
with us on this video
their app is amazing go check them out
on poly.com we've got a bunch of other
amazing render challenges on this
channel so if you guys have not seen
them please check it out there'll be a
link in the description and also if you
haven't seen peter's scooty definitely
check that out that just dropped as well
so we've got a bunch of amazing videos
if you're new to the channel welcome and
check out what we have to offer